>> What's a way to put the standard deviation in words? Just to warn you, this
is going to be a really tricky quiz. Maybe read them out loud slowly. You'll
have to think about each one, but this will really help you understand what the
standard deviation is. Are you ready? Here are your options. More than one of
these could be correct. I put parentheses to specify the procedure. So, for
example, with this one here, I could have put parentheses around just some of
absolute deviations, which would mean you find each absolute deviation, you sum
them up, and then you square it. But instead I put the parentheses here, which
means you take the absolute deviation, you square each one, and then you take
the sum. This one's a little more complicated. This basically means that you sum
each square deviation, then you divide it by n, and then you take the square
root. So this will be very tricky. Go through each one of them and try and see
if it'll give you the same thing as the standard deviation formula here. Good
luck.